>>> I'VE CALLED THE NATIONAL
GUARD.
I HAVE CALLED 911.
I'VE CALLED EVERYBODY.
AGENTS KEEP TELLING ME I'M ON A
LIST.
I DON'T WANT TO BE ON A LIST.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT NOTHING ELSE.
THIS MAN IS NOT ABOUT TO DIE
HERE ON 9/11.
THIS MAN NEEDS HELP.
>> THIS IS A BUFFALO RESIDENT
WHO IS BEING HAILED AS A HERO.
SHE WAS AT HOME WITH HER
BOYFRIEND ON CHRISTMAS EVE AS A
DEADLY WINTER STORM WAS
BATTERING WESTERN NEW YORK WHEN
SHE HEARD A CRY FOR HELP.
IT WAS 64-YEAR-OLD JOE WHITE,
WHO GOES BY JOEY, AND IS
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AND
LIVES IN A GROUP HOME.
HE FOUND HIMSELF CAUGHT IN THE
STORM OUTSIDE OF AUTREY'S HOME
AFTER HIS SISTER BELIEVES HE
TRIED TO WALK HOME IN BLIZZARD
CONDITIONS.
WHEN SHE FOUND HIM, HE WAS IN
PAIN, UNDERSTANDABLY SCARED AND
SHOWING SIGNS OF FROSTBITE.
SHE BROUGHT HIM INSIDE AND GOT
OFF HIS CLOTHES AND BEGAN
WARMING HIM UP WITH A HAIR
DRYER.
AFTER HER CALLS WENT UNHEEDED,
SHE KNEW HE NEEDED SERIOUS
MEDICAL CONDITION.
>> HE HAD THIS BAG ON HIS HANDS.
IT WAS FROZEN TO HIS HANDS,
OKAY?
I CUT IT OFF.
AFTER I CUT IT OFF, WHEN I CUT
IT OFF, HIS HANDS, I TURNED
AROUND AND I HAD TO BLOW DRY THE
ICE OFF OF HIM.
>> AFTER THAT, NEIGHBORS CAME
OVER TO HELP PLOW THE SNOW.
THEY WRAPPED JOEY IN A BLANKET.
SHE RODE WITH HIM TO THE
HOSPITAL.
>> THANK YOU TO Y'ALL VERY MUCH.
I'M RIGHT HERE.
YOU OKAY?
I LOVE YOU, TOO, SWEETIE.
NOTHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
JUST BREATHE, BREATHE.
>> HE REMAINS IN ICU THIS
MORNING.
HE HAS FOURTH DEGREE FROSTBITE.
HIS SISTER, WHO IS GRATEFUL FOR
AUTREY'S HELP SAYS -- YVONNE
WILL JOIN US HERE THIS MORNING.
WE'RE SOAUTRY.
SHA'CARRI YOU ARE A HERO FOR
SAVING HIM.
I WANT YOU TO RECOUNT WHAT IT
WAS LIKE TO FIND HIM AND BRING
SOMEONE THAT IS A STRANGER TO
YOU INTO YOUR HOME AS THIS STORM
WAS UNDER WAY.
>> IT WAS VERY -- IT WAS VERY
DEVASTATING.
VERY DEVASTATING.
HEARTBREAKING TO SEE SOMEONE TO
HELPLESS AND JUST NEEDED SOME
HELP.
>> AND YOU MADE HIM PANCAKES,
RIGHT?
TELL US WHAT IT WAS LIKE.
>> YES, HE ACTUALLY WOKE ME UP
ON CHRISTMAS MORNING, I TOLD HIM
THE DAY BEFORE CHRISTMAS I SAID,
JOEY, LOOKS LIKE IF YOU'RE GOING
TO WAKE UP WITH ME ON CHRISTMAS.
HE SAID TO ME, OKAY.
CAN I GET A BRUCE LEE SHIRT?
I SAID, YEP, WE CAN.
SO CHRISTMAS MORNING HAPPENED
AND I HEARD, HEY, HEY.
I'M LIKE, YEAH.
HE WAS LIKE ARE YOU GOING TO
MAKE MY PANCAKES?
I SAID, YEAH, I WILL MAKE YOU
PANCAKES.
>> THE ULTIMATE CAREGIVER.
>> CAN YOU TELL US, YVONNE, HOW
YOUR BROTHER IS DOING?
HOW IS JOEY DOING?
>> I SPOKE TO THE HOSPITAL
PROBABLY ABOUT 35 MINUTES AGO.
AT THIS POINT HE'S SLEEPING, SO
OBVIOUSLY I DIDN'T WANT TO WAKE
HIM UP, I WILL CALL HIM IN A
LITTLE BIT, BUT HE'S STILL THE
SAME, THEY'RE STILL WATCHING
HIM, FOURTH DEGREE BURNS.
HIS VOICE, I SPOKE TO HIM
YESTERDAY, HE'S VERY WEAK.
HE SOUNDS VERY SAD, BUT GUESS
WHAT HE WANTED TO DO, MY DEAR,
FACETIME.
SO I TOLD HIM WHEN I GO THERE I
WILL CHECK HIS PHONE BECAUSE I
JUST GOT HIM A NEW PHONE A
LITTLE WHILE AGO AND WE WILL SEE
IF WE CAN HOOK THAT UP SO WE CAN
TALK TO EVERYBODY AND SEE
EVERYBODY.
HE'S SAD AND HE'S SCARED.
>> OH.
>> I KNOW.
I HATE TO HEAR THAT.
HE'S BEEN THROUGH SO MUCH.
LUCKILY SHA'KYRA WAS THERE TO
HELP HIM.
ARE YOU WORRIED WHAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED TO YOUR BROTHER HAD
SHA'KYRA NOT ABOUT THERE TO
HELP?
>> PETRIFIED.
HONESTLY, HONESTLY, I'M SURE HE
WOULD HAVE PERISHED.
LIKE I TOLD JOEY, WE GAINED A
FAMILY.
I'M LOOKING AT MY SISTER.
I'M LOOKING AT TRENT WHO IS MY
BROTHER AND NOW I'M THRILLED
BECAUSE I HAVE THREE NEPHEWS,
AND THAT'S -- THAT'S HOW I FEEL
BECAUSE THIS WOMAN JUST -- JUST
WHAT SHE DID, ABOVE AND BEYOND
FOR A STRANGER, WHAT SHE DID IS
JUST HEART WARMING AND IT MAKES
ME CRY.
I MEAN, BOTH OF US WERE CRYING
FOR TWO DAYS.
>> YES, WE WERE.
>> I THINK WE -- WE IN THE MEDIA
AND JUST A LOT OF PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT HOW DIVIDED THIS COUNTRY
IS AND IT IS.
BUT LET'S NOT FORGET FOLKS LIKE
YOU AND SHAKIRA, WHAT YOU DID.
I THINK WE WOULD LIKE TO SAY I
WOULD DO THE SAME.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF I WOULD.
WHERE DID THAT COME FROM IN YOU?
>> PAYING IT FORWARD.
HOW I WAS RAISED.
MY FAMILY ALWAYS TAUGHT ME TO
HAVE COMPASSION AND THAT'S WHAT
I DID.
I JUST HAD TO JUMP IN.
I JUST HAD TO JUMP IN AND DO
WHAT I CAN DO AND I TRIED TO AS
LONG AS, YOU KNOW, TO HELP THEM
COME TO ME, ME AND -- ME AND HIS
SISTER JUST, YOU KNOW, WE BONDED
OVER THE TIME THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE OF THE TIME OF BEING WITH
ME.
I MADE SURE TO MAKE HER AT EASE,
TO MAKE HIM FEEL COMFORTABLE, I
SENT HER MULTIPLE PICTURES, WE
CALLED, WE FACETIMED.
THE VERY FIRST TIME WE FACETIMED
HE DID NOT UNDERSTAND.
HE SAID, HEY, WHAT IS THAT?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
I WAS LIKE IT'S FACETIME.
HE WAS SO SURPRISED.
HE COULDN'T UNDERSTAND IT.
THROUGHOUT THE TIME MY FAMILY,
MY LITTLE COUSINS, MY CHILDREN,
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WAS STRANDED,
WE ALL FACETIMED THEM AND I LET
THEM KNOW, WE WOULD SAY, HEY,
GUYS, HERE IS JOEY.
HE WOULD SMIRK AND HE WOULD
SMILE AND EVERYBODY SAID, HI,
JOEY.
WE JUST IMMEDIATELY BROUGHT HIM
IN LIKE FAMILY.
I WOULD DO IT 100 MORE TIMES NO
MATTER WHAT THE SITUATION WAS.
I'M GLAD I WAS ABLE TO HAVE
POWER, I'M GLAD I HAD FOOD, I'M
GLAD I HAD HEAT.
I'M JUST SO THANKFUL THAT I WAS
ABLE TO GIVE BACK AND ACTUALLY
PAY IT FORWARD, YOU KNOW, TO
HIM, TO HIS FAMILY, TO SHOW
OTHER PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
TO WORK TOGETHER.
REGARDLESS OF THE COLOR THAT WE
ARE, REGARDLESS OF THE AGE, JUST
JUMP IN AND JUST DO IT.
JUST DO IT.
I'M JUST SO GLAD THAT JOEY AT
LEAST KNOW HIS SISTER'S PHONE
NUMBER.
BECAUSE WHEN HE STARTED SAYING
PHONE NUMBERS I DIDN'T KNOW IT
WAS REAL BUT WHEN I CALLED IT
AND WHEN I CALLED IT THE FIRST
TIME SHE DIDN'T ANSWER BUT WHEN
SHE ANSWERED THE SECOND TIME IT
WAS LIKE A WEIGHT LIFTED OFF OF
OUR SHOULDERS IMMEDIATELY AND WE
BEGAN TO START WORKING TOGETHER
BECAUSE OUTSIDE OF THAT IT WAS
JUST ME AND MY FAMILY WORKING
TOGETHER.
SO I WOULD DO IT AGAIN AND I'M
SO GRATEFUL I WAS ABLE TO SAVE
HIS LIFE.
I'M GRATEFUL THAT TRENT WAS ABLE
TO PICK HIM UP AND BRING HIM IN
HERE.
MY FATHER ENCOURAGING THIS, LIKE
I SAID, AT LEAST IT WAS LIKE
MAYBE WE CAN PUT HIM IN A
VEHICLE BUT HE NEEDED MORE.
HE NEEDED MORE THAN THAT.
WE HAD TO HELP HIM AND I'M SO
GRATEFUL THAT WE DID AND I JUST
HOPE OTHER PEOPLE IN OTHER AREAS
THAT THEY HAVE A DEVASTATING
STORM OR ANYTHING, IF YOU SEE
SOMETHING, HELP SOMEBODY.
YOU KNOW, THIS WASN'T EVEN ABOUT
MY LIFE, IT WAS TRULY ABOUT HIM.
I JUST WANTED TO DO THE RIGHT --
>> SHA'KYRA, DO YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'VE GAINED ANOTHER FAMILY
MEMBER IN ALL OF THIS?
>> FOR SURE.
FOR SURE.
THAT'S UNCLE JOEY.
>> UNCLE JOEY.
>> JOEY IS GOING TO HOLD YOU TO
THAT, MY DEAR.
HE'S GOING TO HOLD YOU TO THAT.
>> I KNOW.
>> HE SAID THESE ARE MY BEST
FRIENDS, YVONNE.
>> I JUST GOT A TEXT FROM A
FRIEND WHO IS TRYING, YOU'RE
BRINGING PEOPLE TO TEARS.
SECOND OF ALL, YOU KNOW THERE'S
GOT TO BE A REUNION OF ALL OF
YOU.
>> FOR SURE.
>> WE WANT TO BE THERE.
CNN WANTS TO BE THERE.
>> YES.
>> OKAY?
>> I BELIEVE SOMETHING IS IN THE
WORKS.
>> WHAT DID YOU SAY, YVONNE?
>> I BELIEVE SOMETHING IS IN THE
WORKS, BUT WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
IT OUT BECAUSE, I TELL YOU, THE
FIRST THING I'M GOING TO DO IS
GIVE MY SISTER A HUG.
>> YES.
>> AND I KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE
HEART FELT.
WE'RE VERY SIMILAR.
WE'RE VERY SIMILAR AND THAT'S
THE SWEETEST PART, OUR FAVORITE
MOVIE IS "PAY IT FORWARD" AND WE
LOVE THE DISNEY CHANNEL.
YOU DON'T FIND PEOPLE LIKE THAT
THAT OFTEN.
>> YOU DON'T.
YOU DON'T FIND PEOPLE LIKE
EITHER OF YOU.
WE JUST -- WE LOVE THIS STORY
AND THE MINUTE WE SAW IT WE WERE
SO GRATEFUL TO THE LOCAL BUFFALO
OUTLET THAT PICKED IT UP FIRST
AND WE ARE SO GRATEFUL THAT YOU
GUYS CAME ON TO SHARE IT.
SHA'KYRA, WE ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR
YOU, FOR WHAT YOU DID.
I MEAN, IT'S AN AMAZING SHOW OF
WHAT PEOPLE CAN BE LIKE WHEN
THEY ARE THEIR BEST SELVES.
SO THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING
HERE.
WE'RE ROOTING FOR JOEY, WE HOPE
THAT HE RECOVERS AND HE'S BACK
SOON AND YOU CAN ALL BE
TOGETHER.
>> AND WE WILL SEE YOU AT THE
REUNION.
>> OKAY.
>> IF DISNEY IS LISTENING I
THINK Y'ALL DESERVE A TRIP TO,
YOU KNOW, DISNEY WORLD ON THEM.
THANK YOU.
>> WELL, I MEAN, WE --
>> THANK YOU.
>> THERE IS -- WE ARE TAKING
CARDS FOR JOEY